[Music]
kim kardashian and northwest are back at
it on tick tock yep giving us that
quality lip-syncing content that i don't
know on monday the mommy daughter duo
shared this clip to the platform singing
along to the 2015 track this could be us
[Music]
the post comes just days after kourtney
kardashian's nine-year-old daughter
penelope posted this video to their
joint account featuring the same song
[Music]
and while court sat that one out p's
famous dad scott disick made a cameo
lip-syncing like a boss but this isn't
the first time kim and north have
followed court and penelope's lead on
tick-tock it's always so much fun just
last week the 41-year-old kkw beauty
founder and her eight-year-old mini-me
sang along to a song called jenny by
studio killers
[Music]
pretty good right i don't know how
you're going to top that well kim's
older sister and her little girl did the
trend first writing alongside it quote
we cannot keep a straight face
[Music]
of course court and p launched their
account back in november
and shortly after kim and northie
followed suit
why not
[Music]
you just gotta roll with it but turns
out they've actually been making tick
tocks in secret since 2020. north has a
private tick-tock account so we we do
lots of tick tocks together she puts
them in drafts
she's not allowed to post them but we
have lots of tick tocks i might post one
soon and ever since kim and north went
public on the platform the cousins have
tackled a bunch of the same trends like
this one where they screamed and shook
the camera before revealing their outfit
of the day
[Music]
and fun fact that screaming sound is
actually north and penelope's aunt kylie
jenner
[Applause]
[Music]
but back to the cousin's dueling
tick-tock antics north's little sis
chicago helped her bust a rhyme a la
eminem
while penelope recruited her famous mom
and dr gray said nothing idiots dr dre
is dead he's locked in my basement and
both north and penelope have managed to
get their moms to dance on the platform
it's really lit and and fun and crazy
see musically trapping man most of you
rappers holy spirit activate activate
activate even though kim famously claims
she doesn't dance i'm like a notorious
non-dancer like it's a thing
[Music]
i mean not too bad kim thank you
of course the skim's founder is the
reigning queen of social media you know
social media is such a great tool she
pretty much invented the selfie you just
take about 500 pictures until you get
the right one and back in 2018 the
reality star said she has no regrets
when it comes to her choices online i'm
never not proud of anything that i have
shared but at the time it might
be something that i was so excited to
post and now i can look back and be like
well i might not post that today but i
have like no regrets at that time i was
really feeling it so just don't be
impulsive well one thing is for sure
north and penelope are following in
kim's footsteps and we are loving it
everybody running out the room
everybody begging gosu
everybody running out the room